okay hi so this is episode 104 and I
decided that because of recent events
that I would make a new video and
explain many things because I've got
quite some formalities to still address
in this video and I don't want to do
that in all kinds of separate videos
because that will flood your inbox and I
don't think that quite important enough
so yeah I've got 8000 subscribers which
is really awesome inserts very cookie
cutter text over here to emphasize how
you never expected that but honestly I
never expected that when I began but
obviously I did expect that lately but
still even though it's not very too
special it's really amazing and I am
still so happy that this community is
even still alive and will do all the fun
stuff later at the after party so I'll
see you there
as something else I figured right polka
texts I have like multiple people have
asked me if I've seen it if I've played
the game yet what I intend to do with it
because if you don't know pocket X is a
really really amazing game it's sort of
based of rollercoaster tycoon but it's a
very new indie developed game and I'm a
really back big fan of it's there's just
a couple of things I do have the game I
got it from somebody who got it for free
because being subscribed to something or
something but I do intend to get it as
well actually pay for its give the
developers my money because they deserve
it but I'm currently going through some
PayPal problems which to include having
no money and it's not accepting my bank
stuff and that's a bit of a problem
but one thing that I do have to say is
that I'll definitely be making pockets
like the videos in the future but not
quite yet
because right now since the Alpha has
just been released of the game there is
quite a bit of a park attack-type and I
do not intense actually take part of
that if I as soon as I have the game
well sort of for real that time I do
intend to practice a lot more with it
because so far I don't have too much
experience with it and if I start making
videos of it I really want to also be
experienced at the game and not
completely fail and suck at the game
once I make videos of it so that's kind
of what I intend to do
with that I think there was everything
that I really wanted to say yeah you
might be wondering what the [ __ ] I am
doing with my path works and this roller
coaster was a bit of a top story and to
be all the long story - but [ __ ] it I'll
give it anyway
um I was in shadow xr8 stream on Twitch
and he used this pot I think no no no it
was a completely different story as that
involved you might know him as Steven
wolf actually I'm used this part in one
of his parks and none of us had any idea
what he even got this platform and it
looks amazing
so shadow he found out what it was from
after asking him and basically I picked
up the pot and it was a really big
disappointment because the texture as
you can see it's not like one red edge
brick texture is really great the big
problem with it and this wouldn't even
necessarily be a problem if it weren't
for something else is the fact that it
has only got full tile placements and
it's got only one piece that is just a
big old full tile square and that is not
too much of a problems and usually you
can get some sidewalks to cover it but
the other problem with this path is that
it covers literally anything and
everything in existence so if what I try
to add some sidewalks on the side to add
some roundness to this path it didn't
work out because this path covered the
sidewalks rather than the other way
around and that is why I am placing all
of these planters with this grass and
mulch everywhere the idea here was to
get as many planters in as possible and
get the curves in the paths in by very
like sneaky using of the sort of
planters on sites that's basically how
it works if it weren't for these
overkill of planters on the sides and I
would have completely straights paths
the alternative was trying to find a
different texture but I figured I would
just take the challenge and see if I
could make some round textures with just
this one path texture in the middle of
it and in the end it did kind of work
out it was even a bit of a positive
thing really it's something that I do
like to do for myself sometimes to throw
in a challenge and see how I can
overcome that because I don't know if
this works then everything else but I
think it is known to work for many
people as soon as you have it
you have to come up with creative ways
as overcoming that challenge and for me
that was this annoying freaking annoying
pass set but in the end these plants is
that I had to place around the paths
really did help and make this roller
coaster look a lot better but you'll see
that later as soon as I start adding the
flowers and stuff to it
the only real sort of downtown you can
see there's a downside I do kind of like
it's is now the fact that you know the
path covers have so many different
textures and so many different fences
and things like that all over the place
but it does help also fill up the area
since aside from the roller coaster and
the path ornaments and stuff there isn't
really going to be anything in this area
there's no real room for it it's just
gonna make it's just gonna be a tiny bit
of a show-off on the other side of the
roller coaster I will have some flat
rides and the current planning is to
have a dark ride over there so that's
how that's gonna work now what I also
wanted to really get in here was because
of these very extensive path works that
I had I have many intersections of paths
and I just wanted to mess around with
some different sorts of ways of dealing
with those intersections so the first
one over here was most likely the
largest one in terms of amount of space
that it was occupying so figured I would
get a nice little flower bed in the
middle of that with a sundial it's all
from the most unique thing you've ever
seen I mean this is the thing that's
been done many times it's been done to
death basically but I figured it would
be the best fitting thing in this spot
so that's why I kind of wanted to get
that in and here you can see how I kind
of try to get those curves in the trick
was to very in a very sneaky way get
these curves in make them precisely
cover the in-game grid so that I could
add these path covers and make it look
like these path covers actually have
curves whereas these brick path covers
definitely don't and yeah that's how in
the end I did achieve to get a bit of a
curvy look here without having to use
any curvy path colors so that is that
but still I would not recommend doing it
in most cases as you can see it really
does turn into a a planter overkill
though I do have to say and you probably
know this already it wasn't too much of
a probe
for me at least not in the sense that it
was it was fun to get all these flowers
and different shrubs and bushes in on
these planters because I was like I
always just liked doing that so expect
to see in the future many many times of
just flower placements and all that fun
stuff I know if anybody's into that I am
at least so that's pretty fun I do also
have to add that although I was of
course joking last time that I didn't
make a roller coaster in many years it
has actually been quite a while that I
did make a roller coaster layouts and
made supports I've been working on
standalone roller coaster projects for a
very long time and I still am actively
working on many projects at the moment
it's just that the last time that I
actually started a new project it's a
very long time ago and I haven't really
made any layouts or supports in quite a
while so I you might see that I am a
tiny bit rusty when it comes to the
supporting process and all that though I
do have to say it's not something that
you really lose it's not something that
you really have to learn as in a skill
that it really is is there something
very standard isn't very creative
basically just takes a roller coaster
knowledge how I would even say that
somebody with a lot of roller coaster
can three experience and knowledge but
not a lot of roller coaster experience
in knowledge when it should be worse at
supporting roller coasters than somebody
who is a complete roller coaster geek
because you really just kind of have to
know where supports go and how they
should be built etcetera and it's not
it's not as much of a creative thing as
it is just knowing what is realistic and
I do have to add that I am NOT a
complete coaster nerd so I have to be
corrected sometimes when it comes to
supports that I'm not entirely realistic
or 100 percent going for the way that
they are done in real life and yeah
that's a bit of a thing I also tend to
go for the more aesthetic way that you
know rollercoasters can look which is
eventually why I had to turn this um
which was previously an intimate
stand-up coaster into a B&M stand-up
coaster because I went for being I'm
supports I just like them a lot more
than intimate supports and how they look
and yeah that's why I kind
have to change that to a to IB and I'm
stand-up actually got some backlash
about the fact that it has a cupboard
wall too but because I'm like in real
life there is no stand-up coaster with a
cobra roll and the basic sort of
argument was that it would be
uncomfortable with them bump all that
stand-up coasters are gonna be
uncomfortable anyway and the fact that I
think the fact that there is not a B&M
coaster in real life that has a cobra
roll doesn't mean that I can't make a BM
in roller coaster q3 that has a cobra
rule I mean you can always try some new
things in any case this is where the
really really tough part starts out
because I even up to this point have not
looked into too much English
architecture to note a couple of things
like for example the South of Britain
especially around London uses a lot more
beige brown colours and the north is
where most of the red colors are and I
do intend in this park to go after more
of the London style of doing
architecture some more brown colors and
bright colors which is both from an
aesthetic viewpoints as well as the fact
that I have no idea whatsoever were to
find custom scenery sets that have those
very red brick textures that would fit
in English theme of course I could make
it myself but I would take efforts and
I'm too lazy to do that I did make a
couple of walls but in hindsight they
didn't even work out too well so I'm
still gonna have to see if I've got any
sort of use for those walls and so far
it is over here a combination of station
gems country in which I don't think is
made for an English theme but it does
have very similar textures when it comes
to the bricks and the roof and
especially the very rustic look on it is
really amazing and if you haven't
noticed yet this building is going to be
a mock tudor building I'm quite a big
fan of that's gonna have to see what
sort of balance I want to have in the
park between Victorian style buildings
and mock tudor buildings maybe some
Edwardian architecture in there
somewhere but mock tudor is basically
very easy because it's in essence very
similar to alpine it does have different
patterns and Tudor is most usually like
completely black when it comes to the
beams whereas Alpine is usually still
brown
but other than that it's a similar idea
you take alpine village and you span the
walls and the beams at least that was
the sort of idea that I went into this
building with so I don't know in
hindsight it's an all right building
definitely I'm quite happy about it
since it is the first building that I
tried in this theme even though I would
like to usually mess around with a theme
before I really build it in my Park so
coasters I haven't done that with the
English theme I just decided bump it I'm
gonna see whatever I can create over
here if it's any good then I'll leave it
there and if it's really bad then
whatever nothing is really most of their
can always just remove it so that's the
sort of idea that I went into this
building with and in the end I do think
that it did work out I mean I I do have
English people like on skype and in the
stream and stuff and they weren't they
weren't too unhappy about this building
so I figure it's all right the one big
problem though that I did run into is
the fact that many - the buildings -
have patterns that you cannot find in
any wooden beams that in Monaco second
three whatsoever so yeah the patterns
might not be entirely realistic they are
just improvised things basically using
alpine village so that could be a tiny
bit better might actually want to make
some things for that as well because
actually do still have permission from
shyguy to use the textures so that would
be amazing but then I would have to get
off my lazy butt and actually do some
stuff about that one very important
thing though is that I want to focus on
the chimneys as well I know for me at
least one thing that I always recognized
when it comes to English architecture is
their very signature chimneys very large
very much out there and very well it is
a very big part of how its incorporated
into the building whereas other cultures
like especially here in Holland chimneys
it kind of tucked away in a building not
really playing any major more people
just want to not see them but in England
they're almost used as ornaments and
that is something that I do want to add
in my buildings as well and other than
that it was gonna be sort of copying
buildings but not
really copying Billings kind of taking a
lot of inspiration from pictures that I
do see another problem with this theme
which you might kind of recognize from
the Dutch area is that there is not a
lot of custom scenery that is geared
towards English buildings which still
kind of surprises me I mean a very large
part I think it's the second largest
group within the communities from
England or Britain or the United Kingdom
whatever you will the British Isles
so yeah it's a bit of a bummer that
there isn't really too much because I'm
a scenery when it comes to that entire
theme so it's gonna be quite tough to
actually get some really good realistic
stuff going especially with how
realistic I might be touch area I really
want to watch out I've got many
recommendations still from people which
are really awesome about what I can
change in the Dutch area to make it more
realistic but I actually do want to keep
the Dutch area as it is right now maybe
even make it less realistic because I'm
going for a certain level of realism and
closeness to reality with the park
overall and it would be very weird if
like all the themes are somewhat
realistic real recognizable but do still
have a lot of the theme park freedom
thus to it that you know the creator of
the theme park kind of takes his liberty
to add some changes to the theme or
leave out some things and it would be
very weird if every area had that except
for the touch area which would then be
completely 100% recognizable from real
life so that's why I do want to leave
the touch area tiny bits less 100
percent like the real Holland is so yeah
that's also I suppose a bit of a market
that not every area in this in this
entire Park is gonna be completely
realistic I do want to follow basic
rules of what they look like and of
course I want the areas to be
recognizable but it's not gonna be 100%
exact copies like it's plus there's
gonna be a lot of architectural
stereotyping for example I want in this
area in the British area I do want to
have a tower like the West Westminster
wait the Elizabeth Tower and the
intensity called again and city that
nobody cares
about I don't know anymore Manchester
there we go they Manchester Town Hall
want to get that sort of tower in here
somewhere - but I am running out of time
so thank you guys for watching and I'll
see you guys in the next episode